listen you guys know that I am I'm not
shy about criticizing Donald Trump you
know that I'm also very far from a Trump
groupie very very far in fact so
hopefully it will will have some meaning
when I say that from my point of view
Trump has just completed what I think is
the master stroke of his presidency what
was supposed to be a historic blunder a
catastrophe World War three has turned
out to be his finest moment I think
about it well let's just go back and
review Iran attacked Americans killed an
American contractor attacked our embassy
this on top of all the provocations
through the years and through the
decades all the bloodshed and the mayhem
that's been that they've been
responsible for all the American troops
that they've killed by by proxy in the
Middle East and finally a US president
has enough of it decides to act like the
most powerful country in the world which
we still are by the way by many
magnitudes and he orders a strike
against Soleimani global mass killer
leading terrorists in the world and also
the number-two guy in the Iranian
government the people you know the
people who called who originally when
this happened all the people saying this
is a really big deal and all of that
they were right it doesn't happen that
often for us to go after someone so
publicly like that someone on of the of
the status of Soleimani in the Iranian
government it's basically unheard of but
Trump said no we're not gonna let this
piece of garbage continued sauntering
around the Middle East killing our guys
he's gonna pay for it and we're gonna
send a message and the message is gonna
be if you do this you better watch the
sky because we're coming for you so he
orders the strike turns Soleimani into
beef stroganoff and then we get a weave
we get a week of panic from the media so
it's World War 3 oh no this is the worst
thing that's ever happened to the earth
it's terrible so on and so forth and
then last night the the Iranians launch
their missiles at American bases in Iraq
and the panic reaches fever pitch I
don't know if you were online last night
but it was it was a one for the record
books as far as panic goes media-driven
panic we were told that it's officially
the beginning
of global conflict World War three World
War three over and over again and then
it turns out you know as is so often the
case the people who believed initial
reporting at face value took it at face
value the people who jumped in right
away with all the sensationalizing
looked ridiculous as always because it's
it's like people never learn when you've
got some big event in the early going
whether it's some conflict overseas or
it's a mass shooting or whatever the
reports that you initially hear are
almost always wrong so what's the best
thing just don't react to them don't say
anything you don't need to go online and
say anything but people never learned so
it turns out nobody was killed no
Americans no Iraqis apparently minimal
damage
it was a face-saving measure by Iran
they were they were beat and they knew
it they knew that they couldn't afford
to get into a direct conflict with the
US because of course all along you know
even before last night and how that
turned out all the people talking about
World War 3 just hadn't it's it's it was
always incredibly silly as if Iran is
gonna march into battle directly with
the United States we would wipe them all
off the face of the earth and and they
know that they know that we can do that
to them and they don't want that to
happen because at least the Iranian
government the people in power you know
they're not the same as suicide bombers
who don't care if they yeah I'm gonna be
destroyed but I'm gonna take a few of
you out with me that's not their
attitude they want to stay and they like
being in power and they want to stay
there and they know that if we wanted to
we could just kill all of them and they
don't want that so that's why the idea
that there was ever gonna be a world war
3 over this was completely ridiculous
and especially now because they wanted
to avoid the conflict so they launched
the missiles and they didn't kill
anybody and they and I guess I assume in
Iran they're telling their people over
and Iran the media's probably in fact
the media the Iranian media which
and these were reports that were
parodied by MSNBC in the early going the
Iranian media is claiming that they
killed you know dozens of American
soldiers but they didn't they just want
to pretend they did which if they want
to pretend and then fine you know if
they want to have their little symbolic
attack to try to save face with their
citizens who cares it really doesn't
matter
so then Trump gets up there this morning
delivers what I think is his best speech
of his entire presidency and I've always
said that I think I think Donald Trump
on the teleprompter is way better than
Donald Trump riffing at a rat a
political rally or something not as fun
maybe not as engaging not as funny but
he he actually has a point and a message
that he could get across what he's
staying on the teleprompter and so and
it's not about you know maybe his
delivery on the teleprompter isn't
necessarily the best but who cares it's
it's about the message it's about what's
being said and as far as that goes the
message and even the tone I thought it
was superb it was resolute tough not
belligerent not escalating basically
saying okay Iran you've seen what will
happen you've seen what we're willing to
do so back off now this is what peace
through strength looks like we always do
we've talked about peace through
strength we haven't seen an example of
it in this country for many decades
here's an example this is what it is
so that's what it Trump takes out
Soleimani sends a message weakens Iran
both structurally because they lost
their number-two guy and in the eyes of
the world face it we face a symbolic
reprisal that caused no casualties and
then and then Trump basically declares
victory brilliant I think it's brilliant
I know that I like like most Americans I
don't want another war in the Middle
East I prefer for us to be out of there
entirely focusing on issues here at home
I think that's where most people are but
at the same time we are as I said the
most powerful nation in the world and
there's no reason why we shouldn't act
like
and there's no reason why we should let
guys like soleimani do what they do and
get away with it this is what's been so
frustrating for Americans for a long
time or we say you know got a guy like
Soleimani we can we could take him out
he's been taking our guys out for years
we could take him out why don't we do it
what's what's Iran gonna do in earth
they can't do anything that's what
people have been saying this country for
a long time well finally we get someone
like Trump who's who's who has the same
approach and and he does it it's a it's
it's really a question of having having
leaders with the boldness to take action
but also the the the smarts to not let
that action turn into some
middle-eastern quagmire another
middle-eastern quagmire because we've
got a lot of those so that's what we
need you take action take care of the
problem but you don't did in it you know
acting like the most powerful nation in
the world I think part of that is taking
action and then getting out and you know
and going back to worrying about
problems at home again not getting
bogged down in some 15 year long war so
by demonstrating Trump by demonstrating
Betty that he has both of those things
where foreign policy is concerned that
is boldness and smarts I think Trump
well it's a win for America first and
foremost most importantly but
politically I mean this is a huge win
for Trump huge win if if if Trump had
responded to this symbolic attack from
Iran by you know by sending more
missiles in their direction or something
like that then yes that would be him
escalating and actually now killing
Soleimani that was justified that was
not an escalation when you've got a guy
that's been killing our people for years
and then we kill him how could that
possibly be considered an escalation but
responding in
in a direct and dramatic and in you know
militaristic way to something like this
that would be an escalation that would
be like okay now you really are starting
the war but that's not what Trump is
doing that's what the left expected him
to do I think that's even what they hope
he would do because for them it's all
about of course party over country but
that's not what he did
so major major I don't think you could
it be hard to overstate what a what a
what a win this is again for America
first at first of all because this is a
message that Iran will and not just Iran
but people are gonna realize it okay you
know now there's someone in the White
House right now or we can't necessarily
get away with the same things we used to
get away with and then politically I
think I think if you know it's since
we're still a year away from the
election I'm not gonna sit here and say
he just won reelection based on that
because as I always say people have very
short memories these days and by next
week I think no one's gonna be talking
about Iran anymore but even so I think
to the extent that this remains in the
conscious of Americans and in our memory
I think if Trump does win reelection
this will have something to do with it
at least so big thing now the question
is we took out Soleimani who even most
Democrats would at least admit was a
really bad guy now you have people like
Ilhan Omar and Alexandria Kaiser Cortez
they wouldn't even admit that much for
them it was all about how terrible Trump
is and they wouldn't even just gesture
towards the idea that soleimani was at
least a bad guy but most of them you
know Sanders and Warren and Biden would
at least admit that he was a bad guy but
they said oh you know yes he was a bad
guy but to do this are the consequences
it's just not worth it well now we see
the consequences were they launched some
missiles and purposely avoided hitting
anybody with them that's the consequence
a symbolic attack Asim
polic reprisal so now that World War
three has been cancelled although not
really cancelled because it was never
gonna start to begin with soleimani is
dead how is the left going to argue that
it was still wrong to kill Soleimani how
are they still gonna do that yeah he was
a bad guy
but he deserved to die but we shouldn't
have killed him because because why
because of the because of the the
minimal property damage done by the
missiles that didn't kill anybody I mean
what would argue now they're gonna come
up with an argument of course because
they just could not possibly ever admit
that yeah you know what Trump did the
right thing he did the right thing it
worked out well he handled it well
they cannot admit it ever no matter what
it is I mean it Trump could could come
up with the cure for arthritis and and
Democrats would say well yeah I mean
that's great and all but think about all
these unemployed rheumatologists now
they don't have jobs or Trump could
could rescue a kitten from a tree and
they would say yeah great that you got
him out of the tree but now I mean his
chances of getting run over by a cement
truck or have just increased and now
he's gonna end up in the streets look
what you've what you've done that's how
it goes for the Democrats but well done
by Trump now before we before we move on
a quick word from policy genius you know
it's January 2020 the year 2020 shows up
a lot in science fiction a lot of people
predicting that by now we'd be
teleporting to work and living on Mars
you know or at least we'd have
hovercrafts I mean I was expecting at
least that much a lot of those
predictions were wrong the truth is
we'll always get the future wrong which
is why we need to get life insurance
right
that's where policy genius can help
policy genius makes finding the right
life insurance a breeze in minutes you
can compare quotes from the top insurers
to find your best price you could say
fifteen hundred dollars or more by using
policy genius to compare life insurance
policies and policy genius doesn't just
make life at
it's easy they also they can also help
you find the right home insurance right
auto insurance the right disability
insurance policy genius has it all so if
your science-fiction dreams for 2020
still haven't become science fact don't
get discouraged get life insurance
instead it just takes a few minutes to
find your best price and apply at policy
genius.com policy genius will always get
the future wrong but we can get life
insurance right ok I wanted to touch on
this briefly reading now from The Daily
wire report says Covington Catholic High
School student Nick Sandman has
reportedly received a settlement from
CNN after suing the left-wing Network
for smearing him last year Fox 19
reported CNN agreed Tuesday to settle a
lawsuit with coveted Catholic student
examine the amount of the settlement was
not made public Sandman
also filed lawsuits against the
Washington Post and NBC Universal each
for 250 million dollars or more is
reportedly reportedly planning to sue
Gannett owners of The Inquirer
salmon's attorney Todd McMurray and also
Lynwood filed a two hundred seventy five
million dollar lawsuit against CNN in
March of last year and would told Fox
News saying basically that CNN was
probably the most vicious in their
attacks so the the lawsuit was for two
hundred seventy five million dollars we
don't know what the settlement is
probably not two hundred and seventy
five million dollars but we could we
could also probably guess it's for a
substantial amount I wish we knew the
amount hopefully that leaks at some
point but this is this is great there's
not much to say about it other than this
is a happy ending to a story for once
and it represents finally somebody
fighting back against the media which is
this is what needs to happen there you
need to actually we need people punching
back in this way not just punching back
by complaining on Twitter or whatever
but hitting them where it hurts in their
pockets because usually the media does
this and they get away with it they
smear somebody with innuendo and and
false reporting and taking things out of
context and then they just move on you
know after a few days the real story
comes out and maybe we get a little bit
of a
of an oops sorry about that from media
or but usually not even that they just
move on to the next thing and pretend it
never happened and there are so many
examples of this probably the most
egregious that comes to mind is Kavanagh
but even think about I mean go back a
few years to to the to Ferguson and
officer Wilson who was smeared across
the media as a racist murderer hands up
don't shoot and everything all of that
was reported by the media as as fact
with with no skepticism whatsoever then
the grand jury report comes out
basically clearing officer Wilson's name
we've got a forensic evidence eyewitness
testimony all backs him up and then the
federal government does their own
investigation the Justice Department
under Obama and they also come to the
same conclusion but of course in that
case the media has yet has never circled
back around to say oh you know what we
got that one wrong so they just ruined
officer Wilson's life smeared him as a
racist and that's it and that's normally
how it goes they're not called to
account for it there are no consequences
I'm hoping that this represents a new
face I'm hoping if this is not this is
just sort of a tip of the iceberg moment
it's not a one-off thing or people who
are smeared by the media say you know
what no we're not I'm not gonna let you
move on from that I'm gonna make you pay
for that so congratulations to to Nick
and to his family and to everybody over
at Covington Catholic for being
vindicated in this way and the
congratulations on the big payday don't
spend it all in one place all right now
switching gears a little bit want to do
some some football news here there's
there have been some head coach openings
in the league recently as there are
around this time every year and most of
those openings are now filled Dallas
fired Jason Garrett hired Mike McCarthy
Carolina fired Ron Rivera hired Matt
rule the Browns fired Freddy kitchens
and that job is still open and the
Giants the Giants fired Pat Shermer and
then it was just announced yesterday
that they were hiring a position
from the Pats Joe judge to be their new
head coach which is a little bit strange
on a number of levels because number one
no one's ever heard of Joe judge also
when you talk about position coaches for
the pass I mean wide receiver was their
weakest position and yet that guy gets a
job but these kinds of decisions are
often made especially in New York it's
you know they often make these
head-scratching decisions in their
personnel department and with coaches
but this is more than just sports news
we're told this is all evidence of
institutional racism in the NFL because
of course because everything is racism
this is a racial crisis because we're
told
none of the openings were filled by a
black head coach which is racist and so
the media has been making a big deal
about this publishing articles doing
segments on ESPN and so on about how all
the openings were filled by white people
and that's very very bad it's a very
terrible thing it's a big problem very
racist Steven a Smith a man who yells
for a living he's a professional Yeller
well he he did some more yelling
yesterday a lot of yelling some very
loud yelling slightly louder than usual
yelling about the fact that the NFL is
persecuting black men and anyway here's
what he had to say there is a rudy rule
in place and still this kind of stuff is
happening I want to announce on national
television that I personally am going to
take it upon myself whether is to
communicate with the NFL League office
whether it's communicate with owners
whether it's to sit up here and raise
holy hell
whether is to recruit my contemporaries
in this business to address it we got a
problem
this is some BS ain't no way around this
we move it in a reverse direction we
move it in a reverse direction black men
are not being treated fairly in a
National Football League somebody gotta
say somebody gotta say you got to be
kidding me when when the stuff that has
happened over the last year for this
stuff to go on and we
just go sit up there and have a sports
car no I ain't having no dance
what's conversation at this particular
moment sir wrong now the National
Football League is somebody else we got
to change this Rudy rule is bogus
clearly because it's being bypassed the
original intent what it was intended to
produce it's being circumvented and
black men in the National Football
League or being ostracized from key
positions in the National Football
League
somebody needs to sit the NFL league
owners the world of sports sports talk
television sports radio y'all are gonna
be hearing from me son gotta be done
there it's got to be done just so you
know if you don't follow sports media
which if you don't good for you that's
probably the right decision but if you
don't that's how Steven Naismith that's
that's him all the time he's on TV for
19 hours a day somehow and he's always
yelling no matter what he's talking
about which I know coming from me it's
kind of hypocritical because I yell a
lot too but I yell probably 40% of the
time for Steven Naismith it's 98% of the
time and the other thing is he's talking
about sports so at least in this case
he's pretending to be doing this
socially conscious thing and he's
standing up against racial injustice but
usually it's there it's just talking
about something sports related so
they're talking about you know the the
the Titans punting on fourth and six
rather than going for it and he's losing
his mind over something like that
it's like dude it's just sports these I
like watching it too but really it we're
talking about people playing a game it
really doesn't we don't need that level
of passion just turn it down maybe five
or six notches so I just wanted to touch
on this issue because really it shows
you how ridiculous the attempt to
racialize everything really is this this
racial bean-counting that goes on of NFL
head coaches it's maybe as stupid as as
identity politics gets well probably not
it gets stupider than this but it's
still pretty damn stupid and you see how
this works you see how they turn things
into a racial issue how the meet
does it and and the way they do it is
they just need a few stats a few tidbits
that they can stitch together into a
narrative about racial oppression
regardless of how baseless that
narrative is it doesn't need to make
sense
they just need a few facts and so in
this case the fact is that there are 32
head coaches in the league only three of
them are black that's all they need and
it's off to the races so let's talk
about this first of all it's not true
that all four of the head coach openings
were filled by white people Ron Rivera
is of Mexican and Puerto Rican descent
he was hired so if this is a racist
conspiracy then I don't know how he made
the cut second the offensive coordinator
for the Chiefs Eric the enemy is black
and is also considered a a prime
candidate for these jobs so far he
hasn't been hired for any of them and
that's that's part of what guys like
Stephen a Smith and people in sports
media freaking out about they're saying
well Eric be enemies Ito's a black man
he's very qualified for the job the
Chiefs he's a offensive coordinator for
the Chiefs and look how good that all
offenses but why hasn't he been hired
well he hasn't been hired because the
Chiefs are still in the playoffs that's
why he's not hired they're still in the
playoffs and if a guy is currently you
know on the sideline for a team calling
the plays you can't hire him to be your
head coach so they need to wait until
the season's over but a lot of these
teams are impatient I also keep
something else in mind these teams that
are constantly having head coach
openings like the Browns you know the
reason why they have head coach openings
all the time is because they're bad
organizations not racist organizations
they're just bad and so a lot of these
teams are impatient the Redskins another
example they're impatient they don't
want to wait for the season to be over
and so for the post season to be over
rather and so they hire whoever's
available they make these panicked
choices and so that's why you know this
this Hawaii is a highly qualified
candidate probably would be a good head
coach but he's not available to be hired
right now because it's the postseason
and the Chiefs are still in the game
although they're gonna get knocked out
by the Ravens next week and it AFC
championship game so and and you know I
still think he'll probably get hired for
the Browns job although you know if you
care about the fate of black men in the
NFL then you really shouldn't wish that
job on on any black man or any person of
any race because to be the head coach of
the Browns is a really one of the worst
fates that can befall anybody also there
are three black head coaches in the NFL
maybe soon-to-be four there are 32 teams
four out of 32 is about 13% black people
account for 13 percent of the u.s.
population that would make the NFL head
coaching roster pretty much perfectly
reflective of the racial makeup of the
larger population if that's important
which it isn't because this is all
insane and ridiculous and it doesn't
matter when you're looking for head
coach you're supposed to try to hire the
person best suited for the job who cares
what his skin color is makes no
difference
teams will hire the person who they
think is best for the job now often
times they're wrong about that but
that's not because they're blinded by
racism it's because a lot of these teams
are owned by rich people who really
don't know anything about football dan
Snyder with the Washington Redskins is
is Exhibit A in that regard so the idea
that they're refusing to hire black
coaches for racial reasons is just
completely absurd Steven Asus Smith says
that says that black men are treated
unfairly in the NFL unfairly 70% of the
players are black most of them are
millionaires the NFL pays pays people
millions of dollars to play a game 70%
of those people are black and you call
that being treated unfairly that's being
treated if that's being treated unfairly
then I would love to be treated unfairly
like that
now the response here is to say well but
70% of the players are black then why
aren't 70% of the coaches black now that
definitely seems like a good point if
you don't actually watch the sport if
you do you would know that there's very
little connection between playing the
sport and coaching it at least not at
this level maybe at the at the peewee
level maybe at the little league level
or whatever there's a connection but but
at the at the professional level there's
very little connection between being a
great player and bringing being a great
coach most of the great head coaches in
the league right now were not great
players many of them played at some
level but they weren't great a few were
my grayble for the Tennessee Titans head
coach great player but most of them
weren't so the you know that they say
that those who can't do teach well those
who can't play coach Andy Reid is a very
successful coach in the league has been
for a long time even though he's never
won a Super Bowl
he played offensive tackle in Community
College that's as high as he went that's
the extent of his playing history now
here's the point
he was an offensive tackle for comedian
community college obviously wasn't very
good if he was great if he was a great
offensive tackle if he was like Jonathan
Ogden then he probably would have gone
on to a to a legitimate school and then
went to the pros so he probably never
would have become a coach because he
would have he would have or at least his
coaching career would have been backed
up by about 20 years because he would
have played all that time Bill Belichick
greatest NFL coach of all time as much
as it pains me to say played lacrosse in
college got out of college and then
became a started started coaching and
again if if if rather than being the
greatest coaching talent of all time he
had been one of the greatest players of
all time then he would have played and
that's how we would remember him
so you can conclude that there are these
guys you know that these guys got jobs
because they're whites or you can
approach the issue with a little more
thought a little more nuance and you can
come to the conclusion that they
cultivated a talent for coaching because
they didn't have a talent for playing
and I think that's probably more that's
probably closer to the truth so let's
turn this around and look at it the
other way because I've never understood
this we say that it's racism because
most coaches are white well then why
couldn't I argue that it's racism that
most players are black if we're saying
that black people are discriminated
against in the coaching ranks leading to
white people taking most of the jobs
couldn't I argue that white people are
discriminated among the players leading
to black people taking most of those
jobs if you're going with the racial
angle of the coaching question then you
have this pretty insurmountable logical
problem that you have to deal with which
is that if the lack of black
representation on the sideline is racism
then what about the lack of white
representation on the field is that not
racism I mean think about it there are
entire positions in the NFL right now
where there are zero white players the
cornerback okay there are no white
cornerbacks in the NFL right now none
not a single one not a city that's in a
very important position in a high-paid
position no white people none the last
one that I can think of was Jason Sehorn
and he retired like 15 years ago and
since then there have been none playing
playing that position zero how do you
explain that if three black coaches out
of 32 is racism what do you say about
zero white cornerbacks out of like 100
or more that are in the league right now
you know if 3 out of 32 is racism that
isn't zero out of a hundred racism
this is the problem the racial grievance
thing the racial bean-counting that goes
on it only ever goes one way and that's
why it's ridiculous because there has to
be some principle here there must be
some logical system you're using and
whatever that system is well I I it's it
I should be able to apply it to the
players as well because the system seems
to be well there aren't there are there
aren't that many black head coaches and
therefore racism that says that's as
complex as the system is are there a lot
of black head coaches no not really
well it's racism okay well are there a
lot of white players comparatively no
there's not so well I guess that's
racism also by the way Marvin Lewis was
a black head coach in the league
for fifteen years he was the head coach
of the bangles for fifteen years never
won a playoff game he kept his job for
fifteen years never won a playoff game
so I asked you if the NFL is racist
against black head coaches how did a
black head coach keep his job for 15
years despite never having any success
that that doesn't make any sense that
doesn't really fit with the narrative
does it that's certainly not what you
would expect like if you didn't know any
better and I told you you knew nothing
about the situation and I told you that
there's a racist conspiracy in the NFL
against black coaches the last thing you
would ever expect to see is a black head
coach keep his job for 15 years without
winning a playoff game yet that's what's
happened and can you think of an example
of a I can't can you think of an example
if you if you follow football can you
think of an example of a white head
coach with a track record as
unimpressive as that and yet who kept
his job for that long I could only think
of a few white head coaches recently who
who've kept a job for anything close to
that long and all the ones that come to
mind Bill Belichick Pete Carroll John
Harbaugh
Bill Cowher before you know Mike Tomlin
took over black head coach they all want
Super Bowls so it just it it doesn't
work there's sort of a this is part of
what you do where you have a theory the
theory in this case is that there's some
sort of racial racist conspiracy against
black head coaches and then you think to
yourself okay if that's true
what would I expect to see before I
before I even look at the situation and
before I even look at what's actually
happening what would I expect to see and
you certainly would not expect to see a
black man keep his job for 15 years
despite not ever really doing anything
so that doesn't work it doesn't work
with the theory and you have to deal
with that how do you deal with it well
now you're left with doing these sort of
ad hoc things or you're trying to you
know special pleading and you're trying
to work around they like no no I mean
it's still racism but that's different
because X Y Z and you have two or maybe
just consider the possibility that this
has nothing to do with race consider the
possibility that whether we're talking
about the player or the coach or the the
medical staff or the chain gang or the
refs consider the possibility that these
people got the job because the people in
charge of hiring them thought they were
the best for the job and those people
can be wrong I think with the refs
they're pretty much always wrong it
seems like but that's how it happened
it's not because they're taking race
into account zero white quarterbacks in
the NFL do I think that that if there
was a white player at that position who
was really really good do I think that a
team
would refuse to put him on the roster
because he's white do I think that any
coach or any GM is saying yeah you know
this way this this guy is really good
you know he's great at great in coverage
six-foot one runs a for three great
stats playmaker but now we're not gonna
put him on as a corner because he's
white now it skins a little bit too a
little bit too light for this position
no do I think I need no of course not
that's absurd
and in a similar way I very much doubt
that there are any GM's or owners saying
you know this man is would be a great
coach great with X's and O's great
leader so on and so forth but he's black
so we can hire I don't think that's
happening I don't think it's happening
explicitly I certainly don't think that
those sorts of conversations are
explicitly happening I also don't think
that it's even happening as a thought
process and the other thing is finally
if you are racist I think probably the
last line of work you would get into is
you know professional sports like in the
NFL or the NBA
it just doesn't you know if you're if
you're an NFL owner and as I said there
are a lot of incompetent and terrible
NFL oh but if you're a racist if you're
a racist rich guy I think the last thing
you would do is buy an NFL team where
you're going to be paying millions of
dollars to a lot of black athletes it
just doesn't doesn't seem if you're
racist person probably seems like the
last thing you would do is is is give
millions and millions of dollars to the
race that you're racist against so that
doesn't make a lot of sense either
alright let's move on to emails Matt
wall show at gmail.com Matt wall show at
gmail.com this is from Don says Matt
what are your picks for the divisional
round great question since we're on the
topic of football decided to put this
one at the top so first game on Saturday
is Vikings at 49ers I'll take the I'll
take the Dark Horse there actually take
the underdog I think I like the Vikings
I don't really believe in the 49er
I think they've looked pretty mortal
recently and I don't think their defense
is as good as it is billed to be I think
the Vikings defense is really good so I
think that it could handle the the 49ers
attack and I think Kirk Cousins is is
playing playing better than people
expect it so I'm gonna take the Vikings
there and then you've got so the next
game would be Titans at Ravens I'm
biased obviously but I think the Ravens
are gonna win that by probably three
touchdowns I don't think it's even gonna
be close
the Titans defense is mediocre and you
got to be a lot better than mediocre to
shut down the best offense in a league
Ravens are put up 33 points a game Lamar
Jackson is gonna be the MVP and if you
want to beat the Ravens you you got to
find a way to keep that offense to like
20 points Titans aren't doing that you
know if the Ravens get up their usual 33
points or 40 points or 45 you're not
gonna win unless you're your offense is
so dynamic that it can put up 40 points
the Titans are not putting up 40 points
Derrick Henry great running back he ran
against the page here and for 182 yards
against the Patriots one of the best
performances we've ever seen from a
running back in the playoffs they got 14
points off of that so what unless he
runs for 700 yards in the game I don't
think they're gonna win Texans Chiefs
I'll take the sort of obvious one there
I'll take the Chiefs Seahawks Packers
neither of these teams impress me that
much both have glaring weaknesses but in
a duel between Wilson and Rodgers with
Rodgers at home I guess I'll take
Rodgers this is from Colin says I was
extremely disappointed by your segment
on Jim Baker and forgiveness you
basically said that Christ was full of
it and forgiveness doesn't matter that
was his major focus focus forgiveness
but you wave your hand at it and say
forgiveness doesn't matter very
disappointed in you today mat yeah Colin
is referencing our discussion yesterday
about the televangelists Jim Baker who
is a convicted criminal fraud stirrer
accused rapist and all-around charlatan
and thief went to prison
then came out and got right back into
the television television us game and is
still on TV mangling the Bible and
leading people astray now anticipating
some of the responses to my criticism of
Baker I said yesterday that I don't want
to hear anything about how it's okay to
follow him now and listen to him and
take him seriously because we have to
have forgiveness yeah he's a convicted
felon yes he's a he's convicted for
lying and stealing and he went to prison
for it and I originally was sentenced
though I think forty some years in
prison what we should forgive him
forgive him for that my point was that I
stand by it that forgiveness in this
context is a cop-out and I know that
that's sort of a not not what you expect
a Christian to say but that's my point I
think in the Christian Church today we
have a massive misunderstanding about
what forgiveness is and when we're
supposed to forgive and who we're
supposed to forgive so I I just get
tired of the concept of forgiveness
being misused and abused by Christians
who are just looking for an excuse to
justify following or listening to a
charlatan or who are used to listen
looking for an excuse to to be apathetic
about something because I think that's
when it most often comes up as I said
yesterday and I reiterate again if you
were not yourself personally affected by
somebody's misdeeds it doesn't mean
anything for you to forgive them it's
not your place to forgive that's the
question I had that's what I want I'd
like for someone answered what does it
mean for you to forgive someone who did
something to someone else who isn't you
okay so if you see Bob punch Jim in the
face what does it mean for you to come
up to Bob and say I forgive you for that
so Jim is sitting there knows bloody you
know maybe he's lying on the ground
knocked out you come up and say to Bob I
forgive you I forgive you
I
Jim when he comes to has every right to
say what do you mean you forgive him
what do you you have nothing to do with
this but out it is your forgiveness is
meaningless in this case you were not
involved
you're not the moment the bloody nose
it's very easy when your nose isn't
bleeding to forgive the person who
caused the bloody nose that's my point
and again I ask what does it mean
functionally speaking in that context
what does forgiveness mean as I said a
lot of times it's an excuse to be
indifferent I was talking to somebody
recently and this is not certainly not
the first time that forgiveness has come
up in this context I was talking to
someone recently about abortion and I
was talking about abortionist and how
evil it is what they do and how they
exploit women and obviously kill
millions of babies and it was the same
thing I was told oh we have to forgive
them forgive them forgive them
what do you mean forgive them I'm not
the one they're exploiting I'm not the
one they're killing so okay sure I can
forgive them and and and the other thing
is you say forgive them well we should
be righteously angry at them should we
not considering what they're doing so
righteous anger is necessary morally
it's it not only justified but necessary
so we should be righteously angry we
should want to stop them from what
they're doing
we should condemn what they're doing and
then also forgive them I'm not saying
that we can't forgive them as well I'm
just asking you what does that mean
exactly what would really be the
difference between you as an unaffected
person being righteously angry
condemning the act trying to stop it and
forgiving verse you being righteously
angry condemning the act trying to stop
it and not forgiving it seems like it's
kind of the same I don't know what my
Maya theory of forgiveness is that it is
something it is a one on one
intimate sort of thing where we forgive
people who have hurt us and done things
to us that's where forgiveness matters
that's where we should forgive it's just
like as I said yesterday it's just like
turning the other cheek similar concept
if you're turning the other cheek when
someone else is being assaulted attacked
or or insulted that's not you really
turning your cheek that's you that's you
turning your back on the victim and
being a coward because when you're not
the victim you know you shouldn't be
turning the cheek it's not your cheek to
turn in that case you should be turning
your cheek towards what's happening and
focusing on it and you should be
defending the person the victim it's up
to the victim to turn the cheek and
forgive not you so that's my point with
someone like Jim Baker I you know you
could say all you want I I forgive him I
forgive him you know he swindled a lot
of people and if you were not the one
swindled if you were not the one whose
faith was rocked by this person and what
he did if you were not the one allegedly
abused and assaulted by him I don't know
what your forgiveness means I don't know
what it does finally from David says
dear Matt I can't believe what you did
yesterday by ingesting crickets I have
certain pets that I feed crickets to and
have done this for about a decade now
the first thing I learned was to never
inhale while opening a bag of live
crickets not the smell of excrement
exactly but in the neighborhood
distilled evil perhaps you joked about
going outside to farm some yourself
don't look up youtube vids of insect
parasites I'm sure these were raised in
sterile conditions hence the $26 per
pound farewell my friend and please
don't do that again
I like your show too much I thought
about that yesterday after I ate the
cricket because I'm a hypochondriac and
generally paranoid so after I ate the
cricket quickly I said to myself what
should I be worried about right now
and I do this a lot this is what an
anxious person does you your console
doing this survey in your mind of I know
there's some stuff I should be worried
about right now what should it be and I
thought after I ate the cricket I
thought there must be so then I thought
yeah
parasites what if I get a tapeworm or
something now but as you point out my
wife bought those crickets from our
organic shop very expensive crickets so
I would hope at the very least that they
are parasite free but we'll find out
I'll keep you updated on the state of my
intestines if you're concerned about it
and I think we'll leave it there thanks
everybody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 a
Ron launches an attack on a US Air Base
in Iraq the missiles flopped and no
Americans were killed as of now but the
question remains are we at war with Iran
we will examine what the strike means as
well as the broader Trump doctrine then
Covington kid Nicholas salmon wins a big
payout from CNN as the fake news company
settles a 250 million dollar defamation
lawsuits check it out on the Michael
Nolt show
you